the distance between points a and B is
50 kilometers Xen travels from point A
two words B at four km/h and Zahra
travels from point B towards point A at
six kilometers per hour they leave at
the same time and travel towards each
other at different speeds what are we
being asked for after how much time do
they meet is what we need to find out
when we are not sure about how to
approach a time speed distance problem
the safest option is to use the formula
for each case we apply the speed
multiplied by time is equal to distance
formula for Zen and Zahra we have been
given the individual speeds as 4 and 6
kilometers per hour what about the time
in each case we haven't been given how
much time they will take to meet up but
if they leave simultaneously the time
taken by each of them to meet each other
will be the same for example if they
leave at 11 a.m. and meet at 1:00 p.m.
then the boat took 2 hours to meet up if
the meet at 2:00 p.m. then they both
took 3 hours to meet up let's assume the
meet after T hours so we write T for
each now do we know the distance that
each one will travel until the point
they meet no we don't we haven't been
provided with the individual distances
but think about it what is the total
distance that they will travel together
if they leave together as they meet at
this point the total distance traveled
will be the distance between them no
matter where they meet the sum of the
distances traveled by them will be equal
to the distance between them so the sum
of these two distances will be 50
kilometers that's all the information we
have and we need to find T how do we
find T using this table it's easy the
distance traveled by Zen will be 4
multiplied by T or 40 and similarly the
distance covered by Sarah will be 60 we
know that the sum of these two distances
will equal 50 kilometers that gives us
the value of T as five hours zelans ra
will meet 5 hours after they leave this
was simple to understand logical and
wasn't to let
d but there is a much better way to
solve this problem we can tackle this
problem using the concept of relative
speed it's very easy to find out which
problems involve relative speed when two
things are moving towards each other or
of two things are moving away from each
other or if one is following the other
and so on these problems can almost
always be tackled using the concept of
relative speed in the previous session
we have seen that when two objects are
moving towards each other the relative
speed is the sum of the individual
speeds so here it will be 4 plus 6 which
equals 10 kilometers per hour but
remember if you are using relative speed
be sure that the objects leave together
why is this faster it's because finding
the time is really easy it equals the
distance between the objects divided by
the relative speed the distance between
the objects is 50 kilometers and the
relative speed is 10 kilometers per hour
so the time taken by them to meet will
be 50 over 10 or 5 hours I don't need to
tell you which one was quicker it's
obvious so understand the relative speed
concept well and apply it wherever
possible
there can be variety of questions
related to such concepts for example we
might be told that they leave at 11 a.m.
what time do they meet we just have to
find T and add it to 11 a.m. they would
meet at 4:00 p.m. how far from point a
do they meet if they meet at say at this
point then what does this distance tell
us it is the distance that Xen travels
that's 4 times T or 20 kilometers that's
how far the meeting point is from a and
how far from B do they meet it would be
6 times T or 30 kilometers remember for
relative speed problems the time taken
by the parties to meet would be equal to
the distance between them divided by the
relative speed
[Music]